have you had any sleep I know you just
flew in from Calgary I did let's see how
did you not know um I uh yeah I got it
on my phone playing I like 6:00 in the
morning that sucks
no but this is great I'm glad I'm here
um it's a really cool cool thing what
kind of shenanigans have been happening
on that set that ghostbusters I can only
imagine well it's a bunch of kids who
haven't you know I mean we're organ this
kid Logan who's this an incredible kid
from Texas he's never worked on a movie
before and he is like a full
professional and amazing and that yeah
we just have a great cast it's been
really fun on my side of the CA anything
you can tease that we can expect yeah I
think it's you know it's I think it's a
really faithful movie if you love the
originals and yeah people are gonna love
it so when you get the book call and
they say we want you to voice Pugsley
what do you think I was just like sure
immediately I said yak because it's such
an important kind of franchise so I was
really really happy with how where were
you because your youngster so happy
where were you of The Addams Family the
lure all of watching I don't say LaValle
used a lot and I mean I had caught some
the original show but yeah I mean I you
know it's a big thing so I was really
excited for them to ask me to do it and
this cast is bananas I mean it's crazy
have you met everyone I've never met any
won't leaper sanai men the whole cast as
L sued
al she and I are like friends so I yeah
we're the only person I met but tonight
today's the day who are you most excited
to me oh man I was ready to see Snoop
Dogg just to see him well he's here he
just came through in all his glory yeah
I'm sure I'm gonna see him from a mile
away but okay so stranger things has
been renewed correct all right what's
going on with season four season four we
star in the new year
and I am genuinely serious that I have
no idea what's happening you're like I'm
just flying by the seat of my pants
I have 7,000 movies in 800 shows and I
think with stranger things that they
write it we week-old read a bunch of the
scripts table read so it's really insane
and you really have to just like go with
it well yeah it should be amazing I mean
I think the doctors are gonna do a
really awesome follow-up the last
question is how are you not melting in
this sweater because I'm gonna literally
die I am I'm in black like I'm soaking
all the Sun ever yeah I I hope you'll
get to go inside soon we're back to
Canada where you can be cool again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]